pendant le confinement 54% des femmes
consacrent plus de deux heures par jour
aux tâches domestiques ou éducatives
contre 35 % des hommes c'est ce que
révèle l enquête commandée par le
secrétariat d'état à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes en avril dernier
une charge mentale majoritairement
féminine décrites à la télévision dès
les années 70 lorsque chaque jour à 5h30
maggie quitte son travail un analyste
dans un centre d'informatique de
l'éducation nationale sa journée est
loin d'être terminée pendant le trajet
elle a le temps de récapituler ce qui
l'attend à son retour les courses pour
le dîner
la cuisine pour cap à cette époque les
femmes s'émancipent et sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à entrer dans le monde
du travail mais à la maison
le partage des tâches étaient encore
très déséquilibré qui chez vous fais la
cuisine
voilà je sais très franc je les vois je
sais pas faire la cuisine je n'aime pas
ça qui fait le ménage ce pas moi non
plus une réalité dénoncé alors par le
mouvement de libération des femmes et
par certaines personnalités politiques
en 1973 par exemple arlette laguiller
figure du parti lutte ouvrière ne
mâchait pas ses mots
les femmes subissent effectivement une
double exploitation
la double journée de la femme c'est pas
une formule pour les élections c'est une
réalité quotidienne
c'est que les femmes non seulement elle
se lève peut-être encore plus tôt que
les hommes pour préparer les enfants à
finir le ménage ou ou laver ou repasser
ou faire tout ce que vous voulez
qu'elles ont pas eu le temps de faire la
veille
et quand on rentre le soir c'est la
hantise de faire les courses de faire
leurs pas c'est ça la vie de la femme
travailleuse des doubles journées pour
les femmes
résultat d'une société patriarcale qui
traverse les générations en 1988 cette
journaliste décrypter ce phénomène on
nous bassine dans le biberon qu'on est
fait pour la couture et qu'on est fait
pour élever les enfants
c'est vrai qu'on est fait pour nourrir
les enfants mais un homme peut élever un
enfant aussi bien qu'une femme
mais aujourd'hui même si la majorité des
femmes travaillent la répartition des
tâches au sein du foyer reste encore
inégale
c'est de cette réalité que l'expression
charge mentale est lancée en 2010 est un
terme popularisé grâce au blog de la
dessinatrice féministe emma le mot j'ai
le plus entendu c'est merci parce que
enfin cette chose ah non ça veut dire
que les femmes qui souffraient ça avant
tombait souvent dans des disputes et
maintenant elles savent que c'est
quelque chose qui existe qu'on partage
et dont on peut discuter et peut-être
faire quelque chose lancé les actions
pour équilibrer les choses car cette
charge quotidienne impact aussi sur la
carrière professionnelle des femmes en
une étude révélait que 29% d'entre elles
occupaient un emploi à temps partiel
contre seulement 8 points 4 % des hommes
un écart qui s'explique en grande partie
par le déséquilibre persistant dans le
partage des tâches domestiques
[Musique]